on a dash to avert conflict america's
chief diplomat in geneva to confront the
russians
the mild-mannered american up against
his blunt combative counterpart
the start something to smile about
though but could they find any common
ground
relations between america and russia
haven't been this turbulent and chilly
since the end of the cold war
fears of war in europe dominating
coverage
there was afterwards a stark warning to
russia from america's secretary of state
anthony blinken about the perils of
attacking ukraine
we've been clear
if any russian military forces move
across ukraine's border
that's a renewed invasion
it will be met with swift severe
and a united response from the united
states
and our partners and allies
but a sign too that tensions are easing
if only a little we didn't expect any
major breakthroughs to happen today but
i believe we are now on a clear path uh
in terms of understanding
each other's concerns each other's
positions
russia's foreign minister sergey lavrov
can be brash and belligerent he had
criticisms for the americans but was
also giving them more time
this is not the end of our dialogue as i
said and next week as secretary blinken
has said on many occasions we will get a
written reaction to our initiative okay
on the key question though how much more
time the russian foreign minister was
less forthcoming foreign
they're still preparing for war in the
region on both sides
russia has just released this footage of
its forces near the border with ukraine
but diplomatically there has been a
shift in tone
for the russians talk of deadlines and
thinly veil threats to security in
europe they're now seen prepared to
carry on negotiating the americans seem
to have bought more time for diplomacy
to try and defuse this crisis
the temperature has been lowered the
risk of war in europe receding a little
at least for now
dominic waghorn sky news geneva